transformers was directed by Michael Bay
and this came out ten years ago a decade
in the summer of 2007 this movie was
what everybody was talking about
transformers was back
it was huge people loved it people went
nuts for kids liked it adults liked it I
think it's fine I think it's fine right
off the bat this is not a bad movie at
all it has some issues I'm going to get
into those issues it's tough for me
though to look at transformers this
first one to critically because I know
what transformers is you got beast wars
you got transformers the show they're
kind of made to sell toys and they're
just about robots that can transform
into cars and yeah I mean you can't
really look at them and be like well I'm
going to talk about this film and devour
it because it's so bad transformers such
a bad film I really expected more out of
the robot car moving but like I said ten
years has gone by and I've watched this
movie a few times over the course of
that decade and we've had other
transformers movies so some of the
problems kind of rise to the surface and
I can't help but talk about them so
let's start talking about the first
Transformers movie yay Shia LaBeouf
plays Sam Witwicky a kid in school who
is lusting after Megan Fox's character
Mikaela and he's got a new Camaro that
just so happens to be bumblebee and so
eventually he stumbles across the rest
of the other transformers and this fight
for the cube and there's other
characters a lot of other characters
there are so many subplots in this movie
it's no wonder it's two and a half hours
long and even those two and a half hours
don't even feel like it's enough to
fully give every character in this movie
an arc Shia LaBeouf and Megan Fox Tyrese
and Josh Duhamel the entire military
subplot with Jon Voight the Decepticons
the Autobots and the parents who
certainly aren't annoying in the least
bit and they're drug addict dog oh and
the analysts Oh
Anthony Anderson oh and John Tudor oh my
god there's a lot of subplots I mean I
forgot how many subplots there are in
fact there are just so many that the
Transformers themselves don't really get
that much screen time we watching the
movie the other night I realize just how
little of this massive runtime is
dedicated to the Transformers the title
characters Optimus Prime really isn't in
the film that much and it's kind of
disappointing that so much of this movie
is about Sam and how much he really
wants to bang Megan Fox this is one of
the most Michael Bay Michael Bay movies
ever there are so many shots of military
helicopters against the Sun in the
desert and oversaturated color tone
sweeping low angle shots slow motion sad
moments with no dialogue a bunch of
military chatter that sounds a lot
smarter than it actually is random shots
of really hot women that have nothing to
do with the movie for the sake of really
hot women and of course a direct
reference to one of his own films it's
easily Aundre John Ford and I swear to
God
Oh Michael Bay you really pulled out all
the stops on this one look I got to be
honest I do actually have a respect
level for Michael Bay he assembles
movies that are technically brilliant
sound effects special effects the entire
production design of transformers -
stunt work you have to praise the
production of this movie you can't deny
that about this first Transformers movie
that is something that definitely needs
praised and it's easy to overlook that
when you review a movie oh it's CGI they
made it in the computer no I mean the
physical act of filming a movie and then
incorporating it with these computerized
effects and having a look as seamless as
it does that's definitely something this
movie did flawlessly let's talk about
Shia LaBeouf he basically was playing a
more adult variation of his character
from that Disney Channel show even
Stephens very nervous extremely anxious
he had a lot of tics he said no a
billion times over and over again we've
all heard that in various YouTube mashup
videos no no
over and over again we all get that
let's talk about what he did really well
in this movie and that was add a pretty
good sense of physicality to his
performance he's really good at using
the environments around him to sell the
physicality of his performance and he
did that pretty well here he's gotten
considerably better in recent years as
an actor but he did fine for what this
movie needed to be Megan Fox is also an
actress but I think in recent years has
improved but here in her big first
feature role she's not very good and
there really is no other way around it
she's pretty awful in this movie and I
don't know who is to blame really if
it's just the fact that she was new and
she maybe didn't have the acting
coaching that she needed or that Michael
Page is hired her because she's gorgeous
and did a lot of shots of her body which
he does but her performance is extremely
flat who I do really like is Tyrese
Gibson who I felt was underutilized he
has a lot of charisma to him as an actor
we've seen that in the Fast and Furious
movies his camaraderie with Josh Duhamel
is one of the more fun aspects of
transformers and I have to say in
regards to movies that have been adapted
from entertainment of a similar era like
transformers or the GI Joe movies or the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle movies the
most recent ones this is definitely
above the fold it's better than the GI
Joe movies it's better than the recent
TMNT movies they did their best to make
a Transformers movie entertaining and
enjoyable and accessible but my god I
can't help but talk about some of this
stuff Michael Bay and his writers have a
habit of inserting tons of ethnic
stereotype jokes in their movies and
while some of them are clearly
light-hearted we're going to get into
some of the really bad aspects of that
when I talk about revenge of the Fallen
there's a lot here where I'm just like
really that's like the easiest joke you
could possibly make and it's just not
funny it's just like made to make people
laugh who loved laughing at stereotypes
Bernie Mac rest in peace what a great
comedian has one really funny line in
this movie though and he definitely I
mean it's easily the funniest line in
the movie for me that's my mammy hey
mommy oh don't be like that if I had a
rock I Bush away bitch same as she did
you know
uh and I kind of hinted at this already
but I cannot stand the parents
characters they're nowhere near as bad
in this as they are in a vendor the
fallen but every time they're on screen
I'm like who said that we wanted to see
them just fucking show Optimus Prime
damn it
like show Optimus Prime shoving a sword
through something that's all I care
about right now I don't need to know
about their dog and his drug dependency
and while this movie is technically
extremely well made in regards to
effects and everything a production
design there's a scene in a car that I
never noticed it since I rewatched it
the other day is the most lazy it's so
fucking lazy this entire sequence
between Sam and Mikaela there's just a
white background in the window and the
camera and the car is shaking a little
bit I mean they didn't even bother
making anything pass by them they just
make it all look really overblown a lot
of people really like Steve Jablonsky
score for Transformers and it's really
good workout music it's good for running
or whatever it gets you pumped up but
every time I hear it I can't help but
think that it just sounds like other
scores I've heard before his mentor
apparently was Hans Zimmer and there are
tons of moments in this film that sound
exactly like Batman Begins oh and her
juvie record that's got to be gone like
forever
[Music]
as I said there are just so many
subplots and I really think about a
half-an-hour could have been taken out
of this movie and if they just gave more
focus on say the Transformers and tried
to forget about the whole section 7
bullshit with John Turturro and his
comedic I think performance that would
have definitely helped the movie feel
less bloated because I cannot stand how
many subplots there are and how much of
that time is taken away from what could
just be really fun stuff with the
Transformers if we just focused on Shia
LaBeouf and had Megan Fox in there and
forgot about so much of the government
military stuff I think this movie would
play a lot better in the end
transformers is a pretty hollow movie
with pretty hollow characters but I mean
if you've come from say the Transformers
Show in the 80s and then like Beast Wars
and Beast Machines in the 90s and now
you're so excited to watch a live-action
Transformers movie this is about as good
as you could possibly have it be there
are a lot of bloated unnecessary Michael
Bay stuff but for the most part this
movie's enjoyable I'm going to give
transformers of b- guys thank you so
much for watching my transformer series
leading up to the last night
I still have revenge of the Fallen and
darker the moon to do because I've
already reviewed
age of extinction you guys are the best
thank you very much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]